[Música]
cuando vemos a esta imagen que nos
genera seguramente al menos a la gran
mayoría y genera ternura empatía amor
nos genera un montón de emociones
positivas y ganas de apapachar a estos
hermosos seres si hemos estado otra
imagen seguramente las emociones sean
muy similares ternura empatía amor aún
así a los primeros les damos un trato
paradójicamente muy distinto que los
segundos convivimos con perros gatos que
nos acompañan les compramos regalos
jugamos con ellos llegamos a crear
vínculos afectivos muy importantes
cuando vemos que en países como china
sucede esto irradiamos rabia e
impotencia pensamos en lo injusto que es
sin embargo no nos detenemos a pensar
que acá hacemos lo mismo con otros
animales vacas cerdos pollos ovejas y
muchos más son destinados al sufrimiento
desde que nacen se les marca mutila y
mata prematuramente y la pregunta acá es
por qué en qué momento determinamos que
el nacer de una determinada especie nos
da el derecho de ser respetados y amados
mientras que otras sólo van a conocer la
oscuridad y la sensación de las barras
de metal de una jaula
supongamos que no supiéramos si fuéramos
a nacer como seres humanos o como
animales de otras especies qué clase de
mundo elegiríamos
cada vez más personas entienden que
todos los seres humanos deberíamos
recibir pleno respeto a menudo pensamos
que esto debería ser así por el simple
hecho de que somos humanos pero en
realidad el solo hecho de pertenecer a
una determinada especie no es más que
una clasificación biológica no es lo que
determina que nos puedan dañar lo
relevante para este punto es algo mucho
más simple nuestra capacidad de sentir y
sufrir es decir de ser sujetos
sintientes
podemos pensar entonces es una
característica exclusiva de los seres
humanos los animales sienten la
respuesta clara de sí está comprobado
que vertebrados e invertebrados incluso
como pulpos o calamares poseen
terminaciones nerviosas similares a las
nuestras pueden sentir dolor tener
emociones pueden crear vínculos
afectivos formar familias tener deseos e
intereses todas las personas que nos
encontramos acá presentes tenemos
intereses y deseamos que sean respetados
más allá de nuestra religión
nacionalidad el color de piel sexo
género las personas haríamos cualquier
cosa por evitar o disminuir el
sufrimiento de alguien está claro que
cada animal cada individuo con sus
particularidades que lo definen es
alguien y no algo
no obstante los seres humanos pensamos
siempre que solo nosotros merecemos
consideración en consecuencia tratamos a
los demás animales como si fueran cosas
objetos que tienen el mismo valor legal
que cualquier otra propiedad explotados
diariamente de las formas más terribles
que podamos imaginar la raíz de esta
discriminación no es muy distinta a la
que sufren diversos individuos que
pertenecen a distintos grupos oprimidos
como es el racismo el sexismo
en donde intereses similares son
tratados de forma desigual un ejemplo
claro de esto es cuando a una mujer por
el solo hecho de ser mujer se le paga
mucho menos o tienen que demostrar mucho
más el nivel de su trabajo frente a un
compañero hombre que hace exactamente la
misma labor
a lo largo de la historia de nuestras
sociedades han etiquetado estas
injusticias se han posicionado y han
luchado contra ellas
hoy en día continuamos luchando
sin embargo hay una discriminación
todavía mayor o una discriminación
opacada por nuestras tradiciones nuestra
cultura nuestras costumbres nuestros
hábitos de consumo una discriminación
que apenas vemos se llama este sismo
el especismo básicamente es la
discriminación que se da en función de
la especie este tipo de discriminación
presupone que los intereses de un
individuo son de menor importancia por
el hecho de pertenecer a una especie
animal diferente en la mayoría de
sociedades estamos acostumbrados a ver a
los demás animales como sujeto de
discriminación
la forma en la que esta discriminación
sucede y su gravedad difiere en cada
lugar y algunos animales son tratados
peor en algunos lugares que en otros por
ejemplo perros vacas y delfines son
tratados de formas muy diferentes según
la sociedad en la que estemos hablando
pero algo que si tienen en común la
mayoría de las sociedades es que al
menos algunas especies se les trata de
forma muy perjudicial estos animales
normalmente son utilizados para
entretenimiento ropa experimentación
entre muchos otros más usos
pero la industria que mayor cantidad de
víctimas genera sin duda alguna es la
alimentaria y es por eso que hoy me
quiero centrar en ese punto no sin antes
recordar que prácticas injusticias
similares suceden en otros tipos de
explotación animal me gustaría empezar
mostrándoles las estadísticas las cuales
son bastante impresionantes cada día se
matan aproximadamente más de 4.600
millones de animales es decir más de la
mitad de la población humana actual es
que se estima es de 7.700 millones esto
se traduce en un billón 684 mil millones
de animales asesinados por año tomando
en cuenta estos datos podríamos decir
que en menos de un mes se matan más
animales que todas las personas que han
vivido en 200.000 años de la historia de
la humanidad
gran parte de nuestra carne proviene de
granjas intensivas enorme en sistemas
industriales que albergan miles de
animales diseñados para hacerlo más
eficientes que puedan no les importan
muchas cosas como la calidad de vida o
el bienestar de estos individuos a los
cerdos se les mantienen cobertizos
gigantes sin ventanas y jamás llegan a
ver la luz del sol
a las cerdas se las mantiene en corrales
pequeños tan pequeños que ni siquiera
pueden darse la vuelta en este tipo de
jaulas dan a luz a camadas de cerditos
uno después de otro hasta que su turno
es ser llevado al matadero a las vacas
continuamente se las inseminar
artificialmente esto se hace para
garantizar su reproducción y así su
suministro de leche pero son separadas
de sus crías horas después del
nacimiento confinadas las obligan a
alimentarse constantemente para que en
orden más rápido pero la peor parte se
la llevan los pollos en las granjas
intensivas se mantienen en un número tan
grande y tan cerca uno de otros que no
pueden formar estructuras sociales
naturales por lo que empiezan a atacarse
unos a otros para evitar que se lastimen
y sobre todo para evitar pérdidas
económicas la industria lo que hace es
cortarles el pico y las garras esto
normalmente se hace sin anestesia
los pollos que son utilizados para carne
normalmente están modificados
genéticamente de forma que engordan tan
rápido que ni siquiera pueden soportar
el peso de su propio cuerpo y terminan
quebrando se las patas o teniendo
problemas respiratorios
en la industria luego a los pollitos
machos se les considera absolutamente
inútiles ya que no son aptos para la
producción de carne y tampoco pueden
poner huevos entonces minutos después
del nacimiento son gaseados triturados y
molidos cientos de millones de pollitos
son asesinados de esta manera cada año
y todo esto es legal nos enseñaron desde
que somos pequeños a través de dibujos
animados historias infantiles libros
relatos e incluso juguetes que los
animales que comemos están para eso nos
educaron desde que tenemos conciencia la
realidad que estos animales viven
felizmente en pastos verdes contentos de
darnos su leche y su carne no nos
enseñaron a verlos como individuos que
sienten no nos enseñaron a verlos como
individuos que aman nunca hablamos sobre
sus intereses o deseos y nunca hablamos
sobre sus historias especialmente sus
historias de resistencia
rara vez escuchamos sus historias porque
vivimos en un sistema que está
construido para minimizarlas
jaulas cajones canaletas picanas
eléctricas sistemas utilizados y
especializados para hacer vulnerables a
los animales y para que no se resistan
sin embargo aún así ellos luchan en cada
oportunidad que tienen
beyonce es un ejemplo de animales que
luchan ella es una gallina que se lanzó
del camión que la estaba transportando
al matadero tuvo la suerte de ser
rescatada por una persona que la
encontraría en la calle y tras su
recuperación vive hoy felizmente en un
santuario en el estado de georgia en
eeuu y un caso que a mí particularmente
me conmueve mucho quizás por la cercanía
es el caso del 66 es una ternera que
nació en frente del matadero de morón
acá en la provincia de buenos aires sea
y nació en medio de la bosta y el terror
de las de su especie fue rescatada por
activistas que se encontraban en la zona
lamentablemente no así tuvo la misma
suerte su madre quien pese a haber dado
a luz ese mismo día fue asesinada en el
matadero
6 era una bebé recién nacida que no
tenía su madre por lo cual necesito y
obtuvo en muchas formas humanas una
sustituta materna y a pesar de haber
estado muy cerca de la muerte en muchas
oportunidades 6 resistió y luchó y hoy
vive en completa libertad en un
santuario de animales en la provincia de
córdoba y nuevamente la pregunta es por
qué sucede todo esto la realidad es que
los seres humanos no estamos muy
acostumbrados a cuestionarnos muchas de
las cosas que hacemos mucho menos nos
cuestionamos de dónde sale lo que
comemos o lo que vestimos
particularmente creo que una de las
cosas más hermosas que podemos tener
como seres humanos es el razonamiento y
la empatía sin embargo hemos creado el
arte desconectarnos de lo que realmente
estamos comiendo disociamos
cognitivamente es lo que comemos al
sujeto se intenta y con intereses que
ella pero hay algo que podemos hacer
ahora mismo mientras estoy acá hablando
ahora muerto alrededor de 38 millones
880 mil animales solo para fines
alimenticios necesitamos recuperar
nuestra relación con las otras especies
alejarnos del antropocentrismo que nos
pone en una situación de superioridad
supongamos que no supiéramos si fuéramos
a nacer como seres humanos o como
animales de otras especies qué clase de
mundo elegiríamos si pensáramos
honestamente seguramente es cogeríamos
un mundo en el que se respetarse a los
animales esto indica que la actitud de
desconsideración hacia éstos no está
justificada
qué pasaría si miramos con detenimiento
y pensamos que la carne de ese animal
que está entre dos rebanadas de pan
fuera la de nuestro perro nos daría lo
mismo porque nos da lo mismo 6 la de
otra especie
mi objetivo hoy no es que dejen de comer
animales mi objetivo es que lo piensen
cuando tengan acariciando a su perro oa
su gato mi objetivo es que reflexionen
sobre esto se informen y tomen una
decisión al respecto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]